hey everybody and welcome to a complete
wild ride with stevo this week we have
preston lacy who is the only remaining
og jackass cast member that we had not
got the jackass puzzle is complete and
let me tell you something about
this movie coming out as the premiere
approached as i did all the press for it
my girl got involved of trying to make
me look doper she's a stylist and she
took charge and all of a sudden i see
how i need to be paying more attention
to looking dope all the time and why
wouldn't i include my socks in that
so dude i'm all about stance socks now
look at these dope babies right it's not
time to wear garbage on your feet
anymore and you know what stance makes
all kinds of super comfortable super
soft super quality stuff not just socks
but these shorts come from stance man i
love them i love them because i decided
on being stylish from head to toe from
here on out and you should too so you
want 15 off your first order from stance
i think it would be a good idea to take
me up on that how do you get it you go
to stance.com
you use the promo code stevo and you
enjoy 15
off your first order you heard it from
me baby special treat for the wild ride
listeners so get on over to stance.com
use the promo code stevo now let's get
into it
yeah dude
taking it all in
all right 10 things i didn't know about
preston lacy you ever read those no no
no
the net worth ones are what's hilarious
everybody thinks we're all rich
not me
they uh
they say i got 2.5 million really yeah
i think mine says three
number seven he likes his privacy
that is true that's true
ah we're recording everywhere yes sir
reporting everywhere
who doesn't like their privacy
statement is that that was number seven
you want to hear the rest later he likes
fresh air
all right well then there we go
ladies and gentlemen preston lacy
yeah dude completing the jackass puzzle
the final piece dude you got the old
seventh banana
yeah dude and and what's really cool is
that there are so many comments from
people
saying wow now you got noxio all you
need is preston and then you've had
everybody wow
yeah the bar is set pretty high though
i mean it's uh
it's i'm looking forward to it you know
i think um i've been trying to get you
on the podcast for a long time according
to the internet he's quite dashing these
days
yeah
knoxville yeah yeah they're loving him
i'm loving him with the silver fox yeah
do you know about the um
the website thing
scott [ __ ] was looking up all the
jackass guys websites
he types in johnnyknoxville.com
finds it to be available for purchase
and i bought it
wait until you see the website i built
for him i'll make it live in like
another in all those years he didn't
think to get janoxville.com that's funny
yeah and and i mean whoever had it it
just lapsed or i mean it couldn't have
been available for purchase the whole
time yeah i have no idea it's crazy
though yeah we have no idea what window
of opportunity we we discovered that in
but he never owned it right it was never
his i
i don't know because he when you brought
up the website he was like i don't got a
website like yeah
he's like against it or something but in
any case yeah you said according to the
internet he's dashing and that was what
i thought when what am i going to build
and um i thought
a funny thing about his gray hair
so what i built is knoxville pops up
like as we've known him for decades jet
black hair he says i'm johnny knoxville
and then dicks fly in and just come all
over his head and he's vigorously
shampooing in the comment until his hair
turns gray
i think he'd be down with that
he loves it yeah yeah
it's right down his wheelhouse yeah he
loves it but that's not
it okay
you met knoxville on a television
commercial audition
well there's a lot of different versions
of how we met well let me tell you my
version
because
okay you tell me your version then i'll
tell you the version we man told the new
york times
i'm trying to curb my uh my propensity
for telling people their own stories and
my version of it
real quick tell me your version of i
mean i just know that that uh he met on
an audition for a commercial and and he
had the idea to try to eat 50 eggs and
he said oh hey man i'm doing this thing
i think you'd be great for it
his uh
ex-wife owned a clothing company
and i had met her through another friend
and she had me haul
clothing supplies you know yards of uh
what do you call that uh style yeah
textile stuff around where they were
sewing and everything and we had big
loads she would uh big loads that's
funny she would uh have knoxville come
with me and we just started business
stuff you know he started telling me
about this show and everything and i
told him the show sounds horrible and
stupid and violent i said you and i
should do like a you know leno you know
mcmahon thing right there you know let's
do it he goes let's he goes let's try
this then if this doesn't work we'll try
something else you know and so he had me
write him ideas and i wrote him like 10
ideas and he said you're going to do all
these ideas so the
the joke about how jackass was written
by preston lacy was founded in truth
not really i was when i was a writer in
the beginning yeah
where did that come from like somebody
said oh who comes up with the ideas and
the answer was president lacy right i
was on imdb back when imdb was just
beginning out and starting who uh was
that quote from
was it we man said president kristen
chris pious did yeah preston lacy right
and then that just everybody starts
saying all the interviews
it's so good but i tell you that has not
opened any doors across the world that
in a bus pass i'll get you on the bus
[ __ ]
what were some of those original ideas
that you wrote gosh i i would have to
meet chase and we man for sure that's
one of my favorite um bits oh the pp guy
where i peed myself right right yeah
that one she's so hard to remember now
it's been so jeff said i love your idea
but you've got to convince wee-man to do
it and he's kind of hard to convince
this stuff i didn't know him so i had to
tell we men the first day i met him this
is what we're gonna do again in our
underpants and go through west hollywood
chasing each other around and he was
like
that might be funny
okay wow
that's so funny i wonder if uh if jeff
tremaine pitched it to him if if he
would have been
like would have been less receptive if
it came from someone else
right maybe when you said you were
hauling stuff that's because you're
driving a truck
a pickup truck then just yeah i just i
swear i did for extra money when i first
moved to california is i hauled
furniture and you just do odd jobs and
stuff and i pick up trucks so you didn't
meet noxa on a audio no i met him
through uh uh beautiful jason the guy
who uh shot him with a taser yeah yeah
that's what i i meant
all right yeah but then also i said so
many stupid things in interviews and
they caught on i said that i went to
open audition with 500 people and i ate
a whole bunch of bananas with the peels
on and that's when they hired me on the
spot you went to an open audition for
jackets with 500 different contestants
and that's what i had heard it was like
an open casting call that was crazy
[Music]
terrible idea
but that's just knoxville describing it
you hadn't seen like the no that was
before i hadn't seen any video at all
you know and then he asked me right
around that same time he wanted me to
run and run drive over him with my truck
you know run and run him over wow and i
wouldn't do it but the only reason i
wouldn't do this because i didn't have
another truck and he didn't have the
money to replace my truck you know and i
used it to make a living you know just
barely could barely make a living as was
1998 i lived in los angeles and i made
12 000
thousand dollars that is like and that
was from driving the pickup yeah and
it's like how did you even make it you
know what i mean so there's no truth to
the audition story did you ever uh like
uh audition for commercials or
no it's never been in a commercial with
giant oxford my version's wrong
you've never been in any commercials
i've been in a bunch of commercials just
none with him okay then with john
knoxville so you were like yeah you're
like becoming an actor yeah yeah i want
to be actually i was on the tonight show
with jay leno um for almost two years
doing the skits they do at the beginning
of the show yeah i did a lot of skits on
there nice that's a legit gig now i've
been super candid i've always spoken up
uh about how for the first season of
jackass i made less than 1500 bucks oh
yeah same oh yeah like
i think that bam did like really well
because he kind of came in as a producer
like he had the whole cky thing going i
was uh it was like a 250 or 300 purse
done and we went to florida where i met
you and i came back and i had like 15
stunts and tripp taylor called me in and
said we have made a change it's now
three stunts for 300 bucks oh yeah yeah
and
by then it was the second season yeah i
paid per stunt on the second oh yeah
absolutely absolutely
because they uh we all got scrutiny
they um
you know after the second season all
right sorry i have the first season here
and i'd made the purse stunt bit but
then they paid me 2 000 per episode on
the second season and the third season
did they pay up front or just like in a
week like half up front wow and and so
after taxes i'm half up front was uh ten
thousand bucks now if i didn't go on the
road with you i would i would have been
a bill to make it you know that's the
don't try this at home tour
yeah no i had a job driving a limousine
at that time and i had a hug
took some people out on the town had a
great time went great and then all of a
sudden they called and said hey
um we've noticed that that was one of
the guys from jackass on there we
thought we were going to be pranked we'd
like our money back and my boss is like
you are fired and you can't do this no
way and i was like that grave and great
stripers had a good time but they just
started thinking about it and we're like
wait a minute we could get this whole
thing for free you know oh damn so i was
fired from the limousine business hold
some porn people around though that was
pretty interesting oh yeah
because you go out to the airport and
pick them up and they're just
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed and you go
and they spend a week in hollywood
usually like five days then that
limousine right back to go to ohio or
michigan was a sad deal they had a their
shame yeah it's the look of shame and
they also do 250 300 per stunt
kind of in the same same pay league
there so steve's tour did you go to
preston and say like hey man i'm putting
together this tour you want to come on
or like how did that come together i
asked him to go on tour for sure 100 of
that it was um i mean the the old tour
started with the this
shady rave promoter
who uh invited me to come out to a party
with bam and we man
and then like
it just turned into like me being an
attention horn doing stunts and he was
like oh we'll make a show out of this
and
we started booking the show and uh
clearly the shady ray promoter guy
thought it was a more saleable show if
it was more guys from jackass so i don't
think you even got an opportunity to ask
to come on because dunlap was looking
for people to uh to recruit and so the
most of those tours would be the two of
you don and we man i mean it was it was
always me and then two other guys from
jackass okay and dude check this out
the the story that i got that we all got
i think was that that the our all don't
try this at home tour was was uh sold
for a lump sum of ten thousand bucks
and and uh i got three thousand bucks
each of the other two jackass guys that
were on the show got 1500 bucks a piece
so that takes you to
6 000 and then the story was well they
got to pay for airplanes and hotels and
everything but whatever is left over
after that uh
dunlap gets to keep that's the shady
promoter guy yeah now there's uh
there i mean he would call me shady i
think he would have called himself a
shady promoter i've been proud of him
yeah we're very proud of it but
you know
we definitely never got any money for
merch and there was like
there was merch flying all over the
place and we didn't see any of that
and
now that i've been touring
for
like a lot of years i kind of understand
it a little bit better like you don't
get
you don't sell a show for a lump sum you
get a percentage of the door and we were
doing shows that had like there were
there's definitely i remember a show
that had 3 000 people oh yeah for sure
thousands of people
you don't sell you don't you don't sell
thousands of tickets for 10 000 bucks a
lump sum right
how much for ticket prices usually at
your shows
20 bucks right
so guys ohio was on the side of that
hill or mountain out there thousands of
people there yeah so so i'm thinking in
retrospect
that
you know like i got three thousand bucks
you know president got 1500 bucks like
whoever else got 1500 bucks but i'm not
even mad about that because
had i been making that kind of money
back then it wouldn't have been good for
me i don't think i don't know huh
dangerous
yeah
man
have you have you heard from him at all
i ran into him at a bar or something in
l.a he was completely super nice i had
the best conversation with him not long
ago
you know he was just talking to me i
asked him about how that all worked and
stuff he said it was just a fax machine
business he said you just sent faxes and
waited for him to come in you know did
the different venues and stuff right
right you send out taxes and get faxes
back in i mean to be fair nobody
like in the legitimate entertainment
industry
wanted to [ __ ] with me or any of us you
know like that this this
rave promoter was like the best we were
gonna get and
you know to his credit he
carted us all over the damn world man he
made a big deal out of us some places
you want to go for sure yeah yeah i mean
you guys went to europe you did all
sorts of [ __ ] yeah extensive tours in
europe yeah one of my favorite things
was when i was uh in amsterdam
swallowing uh a condom full of weed to
smuggle it
into switzerland
ah the old days when i didn't give a
crap about my body man have things
changed these days i want to know
everything that's going on with my body
so i can take care of myself and that's
why i got my whoop band people who have
been really paying attention to this
podcast for a long time have certainly
heard me talk about it but now we've got
the whoop strap 4.0
with the completely waterproof charger
that just slides right on man the
technology is off the charts now my
whoop strap is monitoring my blood
oxygen my skin temperature and it can be
haptically set to let me know when i've
recovered enough when it's time to get
out of bed hey you've gotten enough
sleep too much sleep is dangerous man ah
dude and you want to hear about sleep
well every single day it's telling me
like
the precise percentage of my sleep which
was spent in rem sleep how many
disturbances time in bed all stages man
plus it tells me how many calories i
burned
like what activities i'm doing if i get
on a bicycle ride the bicycle it knows
that it's like hey man good job cycling
you burned this many calories dude it's
amazing man the most sophisticated
fitness tracking device on earth and i
love it and if you sign up for a
membership then in your new customer you
get the device totally free with the
waterproof charger everything and by
using the promo code stevo
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com you get 15
off your membership plus the device for
free i'm telling you it is the thing to
be wearing man so go to woop.com use the
promo code stevo and get 15
off your membership and the device for
free for new members it's a killer deal
now let's talk about drug smuggling
and you're sitting there
i got in the weed and i plopped into my
mouth and i just saw it down he said
well you can just swallow that that easy
sucking all that park dick paid off
the best then you choked
i i was at a different that was a
different different time because because
i barfed up that one on stage in
switzerland so i had to redo it because
my idea was to poop it out
damn so preston did this become like a
big like issue for you that like i'm a
famous guy in tv but like i still need
to work i need jobs and [ __ ] like i'm
using the limo job was it happening with
other things too like absolutely yeah i
just had to do scrap and you know try to
make a living until uh
it wasn't until i guess to be the the
last block of the series that we did
they started paying a little more money
you know
and then the movie you know that was it
which was schedule f or whatever the
union minimum is you know
and what's the connection though with
sam macaroni because you guys were
roommates at the time right were you and
sam roommates yeah uh we met through uh
clifton collins jr actor for interviews
oh yeah and uh just became instant
friends you know you get you gotta love
macaroni he's funny yeah i just knew
immediately how funny and then you met
macaroni through preston absolutely i
met macaroni through preston and matt
carney and i were just thick as thieves
right away we were
we were
we managed to be each other's lower
companions
i think uh i think i was perhaps the
lower companion because i always made it
to work no matter like
even if we were on a days long bender i
always made it to work regardless of
what shape i was in macaroni never made
it anyway like dude i've got to be
somewhere and i'd be like oh yeah come
on man we're going to go back and get
more of this or that
never made it and then you guys all did
tv the movie together right i mean that
was the three of your green child yeah
that was that was all me there well
letting macaroni direct i guess damn so
tell me about that you just had kind of
like maybe from doing the sketches with
leno or something you had sketch ideas
and you were like let's let's make a
movie of sketches yeah we had gotten a
gig on national lampoon's pledge this a
paris hilton vehicle
yeah where we played her brothers in a
small role and one of the shady
producers from that we hid up to do a
movie and he was like yeah i can get
that one carlos guy he was like yeah i
can get you guys and i ended up getting
like 2.3 million dollars or something
for that movie
and i couldn't believe it
yeah i mean there was all kinds of like
messed up stuff going on on the finances
oh yeah just all completely shady
illegal on all sorts of levels
and i remember too like by that point i
actually had gotten an agent and like i
presented i was like yeah they're giving
me points in this movie and and uh the
agent was like i'm sorry to tell you but
those
aren't real points
i was like well like a point's a point
right like well
the definition of a point here is
meaningless
plus it's still like um 1.7 million in
the red
oh yeah
wow
yeah i mean that movie had its moment it
was an overall pile of garbage but it
really had some some great moments in it
people when people bring it up it's like
with reverence you know like it's kind
of a cult classic if you saw it
and you were you know the right age at
the right time though there's classics
and there's tv the movie
they sold the international rights
before we even had the script done for
sure that was how they'd make the money
you know they just people and you never
saw a dime from it oh huh when we got
sued even though
you guys said personally yeah i know we
got suited i mention any names of course
but the guy sued us uh uh wanting a
writing credit on there a guy who we had
helped us right
come help us a typist oh my god that's
the last thing if it was like we
surveyed 100 people like i would not
have said anybody
sued for credit for that
oh yeah
so he sued and we had to go to court and
be deposed in all this and he ended up
winning
which he won a credit on the writing
credit on national influence tv the
movie and they had to pay had to pay his
attorneys you know for that stuff they
said they said it must be 75. you can
have stevo's useless points
so he was getting
you win
the
debt that the movie is in
my buddy mick was cutting his hair at
floyd's barber shop and that guy who
sued and the guy started dropping names
out he's a big hollywood writer and mick
goes i need to tell you that
not only did my buddy preston write that
movie he goes i'm in it
the guy was bragging about writing a
movie that he was in this story wow
so you're saying that the guy didn't
actually write it no he wrote i think it
did write one bit or something in there
yeah but he really fell apart with the
horrible things he said on those emails
in the deposition just just just racist
stuff and stuff it was like wow like
when they start reading that stuff out
loud it's just like that dude's
dead you know damn yeah dead meat did
you ever do any other like writing like
you know scripted stuff like that oh
lucky cucumber another horrible macaroni
movie yeah i had a little run there of
bad independent films what's lucky
cucumber about
um this uh guy stars dean bajar from
basketball i don't know if you guys know
who that is is that was that like little
[ __ ] yes yeah yeah yeah yeah that's him
uh he uh wins the lottery and is like
goes from poor to rich and then loses
all his money it was just a cheap thing
that we shot that was one where uh
another friend of that some guy macaroni
met said his dad was really wanting to
invest in an independent movie so we
sent him a horrible script
and i um taped uh four hundred thousand
dollar candy bars to the back page and
he said he was eating those candy bars
inside i'll give these guys at four
hundred thousand dollars
tell us about uh when you when you were
acting in a movie with patrick swayze oh
um
christmas in wonderland yeah i had a
christmas movie where i played a
criminal uh with i played chris katan's
brother
and uh we uh rob uh patrick swayze's
kids from with of their money in the
movie it is a big flop but it was sure
fun to make
i remember you just saying like the
greatest things about patrick swayze
he was i hung out with him every night
spent a lot of time we were sitting
there i was sitting there with patrick
swayze and i said because we started to
be buddies and i said it's a shame we
could never get you on our show to be
work with chris and he goes what are you
talking about he goes i would have loved
to been on that and i said no we went
repeatedly to your agents and he goes
i'm going to call him he goes because
sure as heck never went to me and it was
like man these darn agents just because
it's no money won't do it you know
and it's just like it would have been it
could have brought him back you know
what i mean could have been great for
his career brought him back i don't know
i didn't know that he had he called this
christmas movie that he did his comeback
because he had such a gap in his in his
mind
yeah
and then he ended up doing uh one like
horror series after that
then he did ghost you guys now this is
before ghost was a long time ago there's
a big gap there your
how did you get along with chris kattan
real good real good he was great and
carmen electra too mm-hmm she was
awesome i'm in a lecture yeah
we went and to see uh sting play at a
big football stadium and they said sting
is backstage and he wants to meet you so
i walk up there
uh us so it's carmen electra chris katan
patrick swayze and me and sting goes i
know you and pointed right at me and
walks up there and says he's a big
jackass fan i couldn't believe it and
chris katan was like i was in a skit
with him on saturday night live he and
he's saying it comes up to your fat ass
all right wow that's funny man it's good
times up there though to this uh to this
day uh uh when that's on the thing when
the edmonton eskimos score touchdown i
yell touchdown eskimos on the big
jumbotron with footage and audio yeah
yeah yeah dude epic eskimos you're a
huge uh
chiefs fan huh yeah like i went to 11
games this last season wow kansas city
royals too yeah but i haven't been going
as much to that just because i thought
we were going to be busy all last fall
and it ended up i had a lot of free time
right so once i went to a game in vegas
and one in l.a it was neat stadiums yeah
um
what uh
like with 10 years in between
jackass 3d and jackass forever
like
what was your main thing that you were
doing i know you were doing stand-up and
i loved that and
uh a lot
yeah i just stand up as much as i could
and uh i was the last one to to hold
hope that we were gonna do another movie
after everybody and then finally you
know like five years ago i gave up you
know so then i was just been i was
trying to figure out what i was going to
do i
was thinking about starting a business
of some sort you know do something just
you know have something to do just try
to sit around all day what kind of
business would you start i don't know
you know just a
restaurant or something you know
what was the bit supposed to be when you
[ __ ] your pants
you know there's something about us
jackass guys is our work ethic man i
believe in working hard and playing even
harder and i just got home for a two day
break from tour and i'm getting ready to
play really hard you know how hard i'm
about to chomp on two blue chew tablets
man i'm so excited that it says chew one
to two tablets by mouth
30 to 45 minutes before sexual activity
and i'm getting ready for some sexual
activity right now but maybe you're
wondering what are these bluetooth
tablets well
they are chewable tablets which happen
to be delicious and which have the same
active ingredient as both viagra and
cialis except it's only a fraction of
the price and you may have heard that
that active ingredient is a lot of fun
because it gives you a serious boner and
what you heard is true
so
i want you to know that you can have a
whole lot of fun if you get on this and
you might be thinking but
don't i need a prescription to get these
tablets and yeah you do but
you don't have to go to an awkward
in-person doctor visit
no no no you go to bluechew.com and you
consult with one of their medical
providers right on the site couldn't be
more simple easy and quick
and then the tablets are on your way now
here's the good news if you use the
promo code stevo at bluetooth.com you
get an entire month's supply of these
babies completely for free all you gotta
pay is five bucks for shipping
oh man
talk about a good deal talk about a good
time head on over to bluechew.com
and use the promo code stevo for an
entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets all you pay is five bucks for
shipping
you and your boner are gonna thank me
now let's get back to this
the what do you call it dirty dancing
where uh it was meant to be where i
would go and jump off of a crate and
platform yeah and we man was to hold me
up like dancing style that was the whole
bit that's yeah that's all
not the other way around huh
and then like you know that's the third
part of the movie the third take
my stomach really started hurting oh
wait third take well yeah because of me
smashing him not not the third take of
me pooping the third take of me jumping
on him you're trying to get it just
right because and said that didn't make
the cut it just wasn't it was it wasn't
worth it you know right but the [ __ ]
and and he was he was hating and he was
that he was he was the happiest
so he didn't have to keep getting
smashed he was so happy with that yeah
he could he was just ecstatic yeah we
went for it you know
i mean i guess like you guys had like a
bunch of bits that were pretty brutal
you and we man they do
and all in a couple of days yeah they
filmed them all the same time the uh
what do you call the pendulum thing the
wii smash is what i've called but i
don't know what it's called
with him and zach jumped at the same
time that was a triple wedgie that was
pretty gnarly no we all three got banged
up on that smash thing they just said it
was too close to the
triple wedgie which is just so oh so you
didn't use the the wii smash it's uh
there's a bunch coming out in 4.5 yeah
4.5 is loaded okay i wonder why 4.5 when
paramount has uh
paramount plus
their own streaming thing they
sold 4.5 to
netflix for money i mean i'm sure they
they didn't they didn't hurt themselves
sure yeah maybe it's on like a time they
only have it for so long and it'll
default to paramount plus i'll assure
you that paramount's like why they got
the best of us
so will jackass forever go to netflix as
well no
paramount plus has
first rights on forever
okay it'll go to paramount plus first
and then be able to rent on other
streaming sites
and then they're saying in 2024 a
paramount is going 100 streaming their
stuff only like they won't they won't
let you go anywhere else so i don't know
how that affects the future
yeah yeah
do you guys have a favorite bit from
jackass forever
that was my next question but of all
time your favorite bit of all time
my favorite bit of all time with me in
it is the wee man i bungee thing in
florida over the water yeah over the
water there's
did you write that one no bandit oh
they're right bam you drew it on the
napkin that's right yeah yeah infects it
in yeah
so funny that's your favorite what about
one that you're not in
um
well i guess i'm in that too what am i
saying i was gonna say dark room i have
the new ones oh my god so
funny
yeah were you really shaking like that
oh it was here's the deal so in there it
is terrifying i mean it's as terrifying
as it could be but then you start
thinking you know you're like wait a
minute they're not gonna let that snake
in here only because we could hurt the
snake they're not gonna take a risk of
us hurting a damn snake no way we don't
do that you know so then it's like well
wait a minute no snake what are they
gonna do and then it got just worse it
was worse it was like where's the snake
i want the snake you know yeah because
you're in a zip like you know pj's in
there somewhere you know and so when
they knocked over the uh the snake did
you think the snake was really on the
ground somewhere no president was uh
everybody else legit did
things zach definitely thought there was
a rattlesnake going on and he definitely
thought he got bit
i thought i said boy chris sure seems
awful eager to take a cookie off a
rattlesnake's head with that or like
that part was just a given they're like
yeah chris is going to grow up with the
sake
right he was like not even worried about
it he was like yeah i'll just do that so
just sit here and watch i can see chris
being not too worried about that but i
fell for it i'm hooked on a sinker i
don't know for sure yeah
damn
yeah when that door shut it was like oh
no
well it's funny because on the on the
movie
like you see you guys jumped when the
door shut because it seemed so loud but
the audio wasn't that loud
so i was it was it just a [ __ ] loud
steel door that just slammed shut and
you guys are like oh no and it was deep
in the basement of this old college you
know way down he just kept going
downstairs and downstairs and downstairs
i think your gnarliest bit for me is
that the field goal where oh right to
the face yeah that was [ __ ] heavy
dude yeah that was a big one was that
one take
two takes okay did he get you the first
time it blew by my ear
and it's the only time knoxville ever
came up and put his hand on me he goes
it's okay
that's the only time he's ever done that
that football whiz behind my ears so
fast it's like oh [ __ ] and i said man i
said dude you can't miss again he goes i
will not miss
and he didn't it was uppercut though
on the set of jackass 3d there was like
like famously like a no drinking rule
like we're gonna like respect stevo's
sobriety
and uh
like
you
your breaking of that rule was perfectly
appropriate every time
you know like
like like so and what president would be
pretty cool
was just like hey man look i'm about to
take a football to the face i'm gonna
need to have a couple tricks you know
and like super respectful i was never
mad at once you know i only got in
trouble once on the uh walk the plank
right you got in trouble for that yeah i
got trouble for drinking on that one
yeah yeah that one was funny because
like it just didn't knock you off right
you're just stuck up there still yeah
like it didn't work or something yeah
it should have been stronger to blow me
off of there so funny and then how was
that cannon to the to the stomach in the
opening sequence
that wasn't as as bad as the one in the
oh you mean on forever yeah yeah that
was pretty rough because you had a
bruise on another bit later yeah
they only showed the bruise right they
didn't even show yeah i know it's they
showed jeff getting shot with a damn gun
and didn't show me oh well
right oh but you do you do get shot with
the cannon in the intro in the opening
scene
and then later you see that big forever
both in both movies
right yeah okay and uh pirate in three
and then uh and forever i'm green uh
pontius is dick
oh oh yeah right right right right
you mean like shut
one of those writing meetings and they
start talking about that knoxville wrote
that idea and it's like yeah we need
somebody with balls that really hang
down and every face and everything turns
on me and it's like oh no you have
because my balls hang ridiculously far
down yeah no i actually they dripped
good
yeah so you've definitely had some cold
water a couple times and if they droop
down right
in the toilets i
um mean
just going to know if you haven't hit
the water okay
every now and then yeah it depends on if
it's low flow or not depends on the
height
i think i've hit water it is it's a
shock but it sounds shocked it sounds
like maybe your balls actually hang a
little lower than mine but if you watch
the footage on that look the first time
they hit me and the second time they
didn't want to go down there
no way i was glad though that they kept
in like they did it once and tremaine
being like yeah you got to do it again
i like that kind of [ __ ] yeah that bit
was less about the balls and more about
germaine being the evil guy who always
makes you do another team yeah but that
sure wasn't a surprise that they want to
do another tape right right right that's
that that's part for the course it was
one of those though where i got shot
with a volleyball on a bungee cord to
the face to call the kissing booth yeah
man it hurt i mean it's
major smack the face and then jeff goes
come here and look and stevo's hand is
in front of the camera right there he's
like we gotta do it because we gotta do
it again i'm so sorry
i didn't even know
i don't know i don't know
what was that is it the kissing booth i
just i think it was a 3.5 or something
it was a uh it was certainly a uh
phantom camera bit yeah
do you ever have a bit you backed out of
sadly i have to admit that there have
been times even recently when i backed
out of eating nutritious healthy food
and on those days thank god for athletic
greens man because just one scoop of
this stuff
just loads you up with
75 different vitamins
minerals
whole food sourced superfoods probiotics
and
adaptogens i'm telling you man this
stuff is delicious it fills in the gaps
in your diet you can have it on a
completely empty stomach first thing in
the morning and it's basically all the
nutrition you need all day long this is
going to help with your gut health with
your
anti-aging needs with your mind focused
and
with
just
the diet that you're not necessarily
getting right every day athletic greens
baby it's where it's at and you know i
got a killer deal for you you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo and they're gonna give you five
free travel packs with your daily dose
in each pack plus an entire year's
supply of immunity boosting vitamin d
yeah baby don't turn down this deal and
don't turn your back on your health go
to
slash athleticgreens.com
and enjoy a whole year's supply of
vitamin d for free five travel packs and
man it's delicious so
let's get back to this
oh tons of bits really anyone you regret
one i uh regret no uh hell no uh
the one where they were there was
mentos and soda pop or and that coke
yeah where they were throwing around in
that room oh yeah
there's something about that that just
got me i figured i was going to slip on
that stuff it looked slippery and like a
knee breaker and i just i told jeff i
didn't want to do it i was too i was
scared to do that bit for some reason
you're talking about that when they all
just went in the room and just started
throwing them on the ground yeah you
just didn't want to do that
everybody was afraid of that one yeah i
was excited for the only thing to do
with that bit when did they figure out
that you were afraid of heights
on the
the
party yeah king kong but i wrote that
king kong bit for chris because he'd
played king kong a couple times and we
get there and they're like all right
paint preston up he's getting him up
there and i was like what chris
was that like a secret you kind of kept
like you don't want them to know you
don't tell them like that you tell them
that you'd like it right yeah
yeah dude like
when uh
the first thing you do is go up when
it's the first day i walked right up and
started petting snakes
i made sure that like like uh i i had
this thing
where for jackass forever
i was like you know
um
ryan dunn
put the toy car up his butt because i
backed out of it
and now i think it's like symbolic and
out of like respect of like dunn's
memories since he he can't do he's out
here i want to put something massive up
my butt
for ryan you know like and so
i come to jeff tram like dude i want to
put like i want to really put something
spectacular at my butt
no chance
because i wanted to do it you're too
eager yeah yeah too eager like uh
only jeff tremaine's only interested in
forbidden buttholes yeah
so he likes the chase like if you come
off too desperately it's not fun like
with the hog with the apple up your ass
well i wrote that yeah
i wrote that for a horse though when i
wrote it so they replaced the horse with
a pig
yeah so when's the last time you
performed stand up but uh it's years
before covet okay yeah
so at least two or two years almost
three
and you're gonna perform tonight a few
minutes
yeah exciting i don't know i just you do
get rusty you know i'm absolutely
absolutely you get your flow you know
um
now uh
scott told me something earlier today
that we were talking about bus drivers
and you were like oh [ __ ] i'll drive the
bus
is that like well i mean we should try
that for for a leg or something i mean
dude i would love that i would i would
love that like so much and
uh you drove the the truck that i was
duct taped to
in uh the
gnarly yeah for the opening sequence of
gnarly and for the opening sequence of
the bucket list special i'm gonna do
another
thing and and and i was thinking for you
to drive the bus for that hydro was home
from the parachute thing too
uh how about that man you drove the rv
above 65 it was like the best driving
i've ever seen yeah i remember yeah we
came back we were like editing on a big
desktop computer in the rv wow no that
would be fun that would be fun let's
let's do that for a while i think you
can drive something like this is it just
like i used to drive 18 wheelers 18
wheelers yeah this is nothing how long
at a time would you drive the 18
wheelers you mean like by the days or
the hour like oh you're only allowed to
drive 10 hours 10 hours yeah
professional
yeah that was test number one you passed
yeah and i remember when we were driving
to the the colorado springs in there and
you were mentioning something to me
about like oh this is a certain
percentage angle scott you can keep
going a little bit faster i was like oh
[ __ ] this next level you know about some
stuff just riding those darn trucks
yeah it's a lot different though now
when i drove trucks though there was no
satellite radio there was no gps there
was no cell phones there's thomas guys
and yeah i had a big rand mcnally rand
mcnally map you know it's so different
now big fistful of quarters
one thing's the same is the cbs are
still
valuable huh oh that's a big thing what
was your cb name i did come up with tons
of different uh i use pony express a lot
which is the name of a whiskey from back
in the 70s that my grandpa drank yeah
yeah like a real like cheap whiskey and
it's just like pointy express yeah this
is the pony express which is based on
the mail route from saint joseph
missouri to the west san francisco yeah
back in the 1830s and how long did you
do uh big rigs for i think i drove um
between 350 000 and 400 000 miles [ __ ]
yeah a lot of driving a lot of runs from
california to canada
running dope grapes
that reminds me of the time
you were on tmz for getting busted with
weed here in oklahoma here in oklahoma
yeah yeah so uh
i had a rental cabin at the lake here in
oklahoma and i went down there and
made a glass of chocolate milk and i
smoked a joint and i laid down and go to
bed and i didn't think anything about it
i'd done it before 100 times and boom
boom boom someone knocking on the door
boom boom boom but i thought it was just
one of the neighbors wanting to go
fishing or something i said you know
leave me alone i'm sleeping there's like
boom boom boom i'm like well [ __ ]
someone's you know i'm very serious
about this so i go up there and open the
door and it's a cop and he's just
screaming where's your wife where's your
wife and i'm like i don't know what
you're talking about i'm not married i
don't know why he was where's your woman
you tell me right now i'm like i don't
have a woman at all i don't know what
you mean he goes can i look and i said
heck yeah come in here you know what
you're looking for so he goes and he
looks through this little bitty cabin
you know the size of this and he's like
all right here's the deal um
she's not here uh
you look stoned it smells like wheat in
here where's your weed and i go here you
go sir hannah's little bag of weed and
he was like okay can you put your hands
behind your back you know we would take
you into the county jail and it turned
out that a guy had been robbing dollar
general stores and he beat up his wife
and she called the cops on him and told
him that they were in the wrong cabin
she listed the wrong cabin they went to
my cabin by accident wow and they came
down there and arrested me for a week
and i go down there to the jail and uh
you decide elvis presley walked in that
jail i was getting standing applause and
everything yeah
they it said uh i thought well i'll just
get a bail bondsman uh so i don't have
to have anybody come down there to get
me to be easy and that bail bondsman
came and he had my paperwork there had
my picture and everything on there and
he goes i'm not gonna bail you out
because i don't think you would come
back because i'm afraid you would just
run and he folded that paper up and put
in his pocket and 10 minutes later i was
on tmz
10 minutes that's what that took from
that guy that bail bondsman oh [ __ ]
thank you
which he knows what that pays for me i'm
you know c celebrity
by 50 bucks that's something though
i i'm trying to follow that so he said
he thought you were a flight risk yeah
because most people who did this got
blessed for a bag of weed in oklahoma
would just wouldn't come back you know
because he knew he could report it to
tmz and make more money
but then but why not double dip why not
get the money from bailing him out and
sell the story he didn't have to you
didn't have to even mess with bailey
matt or me being mad at him for selling
the story to tmz
so
yeah i wonder it's uh
it's a question what year was that 2010
or 2010. yeah so what'd you do when you
got out you went back to the cabin and
finished chocolate milk and no i had
that so then i called my cousin to come
come bail me out i'm on the speaker
phone and call my cousin marshall and he
was like
well they inspect my truck when i pull
in there
and then like run a speakerphone
marshall speaker
jesus that's so funny is that the only
time you've been arrested yeah okay nice
yeah for sure
like i said i didn't think i was gonna
get arrested then i figured he would
just maybe confiscate the weed and tell
me to have a good day you know mm-hmm
dude
there's there's another quote
and uh
tell me if
you don't even want to remember this but
what was the quote uh if you want to get
to heaven you got to go through hell
i didn't write that
well right but uh
it was like
there was it was some chick
and she was like wanting to hook up with
with one of the guys oh that's him i was
in my stand-up yeah okay yeah um
a chick came a jackass girl came to the
hotel room i was in in mexico and
pounded on the door and i opened up and
she had on a jackass shirt jackass socks
shoelaces a hat everything and she's
talking 90 miles an hour and she's like
where's johnny at where's johnny i'm
here to see johnny where is johnny
knoxville and i'm like he's not here
what are you talking about she goes i
know he's here i know he's your roommate
and i will need to see him right now and
she starts trying to fight her way in so
i'm catching myself you know physically
you know keeping this chick out of my
room i'm like what am i doing
so i let her on in you know we chatted
for a minute you know she worked her way
down the proverbial jackass ladder
finally got down to me
we'll just say old giant knoxville never
came but i sure as heck did
yeah wow that's an epic dude i'm so glad
i asked that
and uh
dude
there was a time when when you and i
were in mexico as well
and like
i feel like i remember coming into a
bathroom or something you were like
getting busy like on the floor like a
dirty floor of a mexican bathroom oh
yeah yeah i got evicted from a mexican
men's room toilet with a chick in there
having sex on the toilet
nice during spring break yeah
yes he did like that was on the tour
yeah the tour did pay better than just
fifteen hundred bucks a shot
there was so many thousands of chicks
down there dunn and i would try to find
chicks that looked like our buddy's
girlfriends
so we could go get pictures with him you
know and send back and stuff and it was
doable because there's just tens of
thousands of women you know
what what do you mean go get pictures
with that we'll try to hook up with them
you know but with one the guy that find
a chick looks just like one of your
buddies girls yeah and then do the you
know hook up with them so it looks like
you're hooking up with your buddy right
right i love i love how like uh our
podcasts have this like tendency to just
get gnarlier and yeah we just keep
pushing that line a little bit by the
end of the tremaine podcast it just got
gnarly man
it got it it got
and and uh what's crazy is it did
nothing in cremated terrain
incriminated
um
all right do you ever kill anybody
why not i mean we've traveled the world
over man that which is so cool
like uh yeah a lot of places
but not like you guys and those wild
boys went to some
random places yeah wild boys boys was
something else
um
you and i i remember uh
like
before
like nitrous was really creepy and scary
with me like
i remember like being parked outside of
ralph since oh yeah you remember that i
didn't think you'd ever remember that
yeah
i'd known stevo like you know one shoot
in florida so we're like you know four
days and then he came to california and
like as soon as he got there we were
hanging out and we were behind
on the top of the parking lot behind
ralph's doing whippets in his kind of
that maroon car of his yeah and he he
did him until he freaking blacked out
completely and i was like man this guy's
pretty wild
yeah that was my goal every time was to
huff nitrous until i you know passed out
or fished out is the word when was the
first time you did nitrous
first time i didn't i just would have
been
like a dead show or something no i was
at my buddy billow's apartment in like
93 and were you like nervous about doing
it and you did it and you're like oh my
god i love this not even dude i'm
[ __ ]
yeah i was i was stoked on it
um
i wonder what uh like what other fun
juicy stuff like while we have you dude
like what uh
i mean any stories stand out with you
like with the old apartment or uh with
steve's old skate park oh i went over
there one time to uh stevo's house
because he'd get on those benders and
i'd always had weed because i had to
make 16 grand and i made 300 bucks so i
go over there and he passed out and i
smoked his weed and one time up there he
was completely passed out and i smelled
this bag weed and i was like well what
the [ __ ] he's out so i threw that weed
in my pocket and left next morning phone
ringing steve oh you stole my [ __ ]
weed
how the hell he even know that and i'm
half-assed try to deny it that was
already busted at that point it's like
damn how can you know that then one time
i passed out over there and you started
kicking soccer balls off my head oh yeah
you remember that i've seen the footage
yeah it's you and macaroni you're like
writing tv to movie
and like yeah preston's asleep and you
guys are just like
wow i think you do it to mac first and
then you then you both do a depressing
or something like that is great it's
decent you know i mean it's throwing a
soccer ball to someone's head it's
pretty cool thousands of hours of
footage like just in in my closet that
it hasn't even been
yeah what are you gonna do with all that
you might you gotta like
i mean we like we for a time we were
digitizing tapes like pretty diligently
gotten kind of lazy about it but we've
we've plucked some stuff for a video
here and there i mean the drugs video
was like
yeah we've got we've like that and we
haven't really delved into the archives
as much
lately yeah so we're we're dude i mean
we got that wu tang
situation like that that was all in his
entire thing with the tang is on footage
yeah
him like steve smoking a cigarette on a
plane getting busted we got that
there's a there's some some heavy [ __ ]
and just like crazy tour footage because
like you're filming a lot on the tours
oh
can you tell the story of
uh
i'm not leaving
um i don't know i could do it for you
guys
go go go go from miami well no no just
i'm not leaving in general like uh
like with jackass every at a bar after
at the end of the night yeah well every
jack jackass was always the last you
know like
in in in
the first season it was like well you
know we didn't know what we were doing
you know and then when the tv show ended
like knoxville had quit we didn't we're
like so it's over dover it's over
and uh at the wrap party for the
jackass tv show
um you know i'm on ecstasy running
around like making out with dudes and
everything
and uh we got that footage too yeah
and um
and then when the wrap party ended this
started a tradition
because jackass was over there's never
going to be any more
and this is our wrap party this is the
last jackass event
ever and so like we don't want to let go
to it we don't want to let go we want to
like hang on to it and so the way that
that like kind of manifested was that at
the
closing time of the wrap party
you know all right finish them up you
got to get out of here and it's just
i'm not leaving dude we're not we're not
leaving because we want to hang on to it
you know we don't want and so the rule
was you're not allowed to throw punches
you know you can't like assault anybody
but you're also not allowed to walk out
on your own two feet so we're like
laying down we're locking arms we're
like holding on to furniture we're like
like just fighting and fighting to uh to
not leave because we're like you know
symbolically trying to hang on to
jackass because it's over and and and
that happened at every wrap party
for every project that we ever did
and it was this like cool tradition it
was like so meaningful and and there's a
that was it was a game of i'm not
leaving that legendary picture of you
yeah in florida in miami you went to a
club down there in miami 25 cover charge
to get in and they made us wait and we
get in there and we're the only people
in there
and and then uh
a
man in a dress walks by and jp grabs her
ass
um she turns around and and shoves me so
i shoved her back pretty good and then
it's like the fight started at that
point so then i look up and there's
bouncers grabbed me and i noticed that
whitey was there with the camera so i
was like what's the golden opportunity
i'm on camera so i just started going
nuts this was ah
psychopath and they drug me outside i
don't know if uh
it doesn't even appear that you're aware
there's a camera in there you know i
don't you're like seeing red right is it
like your shirts
i've seen it but we have footage of i'm
not leaving
coming out of some club oh yeah like you
guys are
someone's filming outside the club
like and
you guys you're getting thrown out and
then like
just like like someone get thrown out
especially like done he'd get thrown out
and then you just turn around like just
like charge
shards back in tremaine got choked out
like this is all on footage wow that
dude that's epic yeah and i suppose it
wasn't reserved only for rap parties i
guess we played i'm not leaving yeah i
didn't just spend the time
yeah so okay i guess that was just
whenever we were at the bar
i was sitting on the curb out in front
of the the club there and then i look up
and jp goes flying by me and then
knoxville goes flying by they're just
throwing physically tossing every single
person out of there yeah i'm not leaving
it's epic it could be an epic video i
mean it could be pretty but jermaine i
at one of the wrap parties a giant
security guy picked up tremaine and body
slammed him hard knocked him out
yeah big one he was really good at that
chairman tremaine tick i'm not leaving
very seriously he also used to play
harley down he was into that game what's
harley down well you go up to a biker
bar and you kick over a row of bikes
yeah
and then then and then just away what
happens next is just
to the gods
you're telling me they actually did that
oh yeah
he didn't seem like a liar on that sort
of thing yeah
yeah i don't think people know that
jermaine is kind of gnarly like that
because he has the reputation of like
being like evil and like making you guys
do all these things
than a masochist yeah but he'll
he'll go in there a little bit
yeah yeah i have a question press and i
ask this to knoxville but i'm curious
how it applies to you like
when you show up on jackass people you
grew up with and your family and friends
were they like what the [ __ ] is preston
doing or were they like this makes sense
like preston's always been this kind of
a
like reckless guy
not reckless just i was always in speech
and debate in theater so you know right
so you being on a tv show but you being
on a tv show like doing stunts and
getting shots that was a shock for sure
yeah okay stunt guy by any means yeah
still not [ __ ] what's that
when you signed up for jackass was it
like i'm probably just gonna be eating
raw eggs and [ __ ] or did you realize
that you're going to like take some
health i knew there was going to be some
stunts but i didn't think it i thought
the series might last for a season you
know on mtv because mtv you know
hopefully i could get a candy bar
commercial out of it or something you
know get enough recognition to you know
to get some commercials
you know just i never thought that the
show would take off what was the stunt
that you're like
wait what like i have to do that you
know like oh [ __ ] they're like did they
kind of slowly like human introduce you
to [ __ ]
yeah yeah where they i slammed in this
stuff as a
right right right right right and then
were you in on the magnet thing
no no that was dave that was okay what's
the magnet thing it was like at the
junkyard they've got a magnet that'll
like pick up a whole car kind of thing
they had him in a metal suit like the
tin man and
pick them up and like
it wasn't really that like crazy this
cartoony like those are the bits i
really like like you chasing women
around nobody's getting hurt it's not
even that crazy but it's just it's
cartoony it's so funny england is i
think like it's just his creativity is
just so [ __ ] great oh he's one of the
tops for sure yeah a good thing that it
happened it sounds weird to say it like
it but a good thing for me was when uh
dunn and pj or john and knox wrecked
that golf cart in the beginning of the
first movie because that's when
everybody went we got to slow everything
down and then it went to wee man and i
for more of some fun stuff you know but
because i did that i don't know if you
know that exact moment things were going
big like it was just getting bigger and
bigger that golf cart thing is referred
to as the incident yeah right like it
was like that was like whoa that's when
it was like all the sudden oh who got
knocked out was knoxville knocked out
yeah doctor was knocked out knox has
been knocked unconscious a lot
yeah but it's really intense i remember
they're like nobody touch him and
they're like running over so up until
that point you guys were just getting
lucky over and over and it was like
nothing bad can happen and then that was
kind of like
the bummer
yeah sure you can't go into it thinking
that you know
you ain't gonna make it of course you
also can't think of it as we're making
this big movie you make these guys laugh
yeah you know what i mean keep it small
make the people there laugh don't think
of this off this is for you know
international audience no you make your
boys laugh and if they're laughing
that's where you want to be yeah do you
guys have any bits that you did that
never made it to air where you're like
what the [ __ ] why that was epic why
didn't they use that
just more parts of bits that they cut
out lines and stuff yeah you know yeah
but my my experience is that even if i
think oh man that [ __ ] should be and
that [ __ ] should be in that
the the
collective of knoxville tremaine and
spike jones like
each of those guys
as individuals can absolutely be wrong
but all three of them put together once
they arrive at a decision a consensus
decision between all of them i think
it's bulletproof i don't think they're
ever wrong
well that opener on forever is just
that's one of the funniest things i've
ever seen on film ever you know i saw it
i saw an early cut and it still had all
like blue screens in it and like you
know i had this vision or this idea that
it was going to be all cleaned up and
then when i actually saw it
with like the the sticks that were
controlling the arms like it kind of i
was like why are those sticks in there
oh i liked it i like the sticks i like
when they pull out and they show like
it's just chris's dick for the first
time like the way that whole thing was
pleasing hard on that we thought we
thought really hard on that we were with
tremaine that you that like if you've
got all this invested in there you know
like the intense music like the
you've you've created this like
intensity and then to just snap out of
it to peel back the curtain to show
chris standing there like you built you
built all this up and you just destroy
it you dash it you make it all go away
and now you've ruined everything you
built up so funny i loved it and and and
spike was the spike was uh no we got to
reveal it we got to let him in on it and
and tremaine fought
we were with treme we were fighting for
it jermaine was on your side sure well
we were on tremaine's side saying don't
break what we don't break that energy
that's been built up and uh you know to
their credit it's not like one person's
more important than the other they just
take the questions like that to test
audiences and by testing by testing
audiences over and over and over they
had undeniable proof that spike was
right
he was totally right yeah he's not
always right you know but uh
but he's pretty much always yeah
only pretty much all the time we asked
for the dum-dum game two was when we
fought for i was surprised to see the
final cut of the movie that the dum-dum
game was like like up front up top yeah
it went from not on there to being one
of the top bits right and we also fought
for zach's the trivia game um yeah hang
glider yeah
which is just a no-brainer that was that
wasn't going to be in the cut at all
zach with this kite jumping onto the
cactus and and uh and we fought for it
and the next you know it's like a movie
post yeah yeah but do you guys want a
bit in the front of the movie or at the
end of the movie or middle does it
matter no
we're happy with where they like the
pacing of like how it goes like they
always get that right so yeah because
science the lamb's bit was like number
two and that was like
the heaviest one
that's the hardest i think i've ever
laughed watching some jackass [ __ ] dave
and aaron oh my god like dave
oh that's convenient yeah yeah fighting
and aaron's hiding out and he's like
aaron you gotta answer me zach was
killing me during that because he's like
i don't know he just had belief like i
could get out of this you know like i
know i know what to do you know
he just hits his head and he hits the
[ __ ] mouse traps like he explored
everything more than anybody like all
his options yeah oh my god dude yeah
such a special thing man if i can
jackass was lightning in a bottle man
you know i really don't believe that
anything like that
had ever happened before and i don't
think anything like that could ever
happen again kind of we were in that
dark room and i went from defensive to
offensive i got tired of it i started
looking around for weapons and stuff
trying i i had a mop that i used and i
had afghan that i used for a while but
as i was in there i was like why the
heck is chris naked i was like there's a
naked pontius in this dark room with all
this horrible [ __ ] going on it's like
what the heck how long were you in there
for i probably three minutes seven
minutes i don't it was all just
didn't know what was happening or going
on so far yeah
yeah well [ __ ] man
um i i i love you man i love you like
thank you for having me in your house
yeah dude it's pretty rad and uh i i
gotta say i feel really weird about the
idea of going on tour and you're the
driver but at the same time i can see
how it makes all kinds of sense it's
kind of funny i think it's i think
it's epic you know and we could have you
like you know like opening the show
so uh
you know it's like my opener is [ __ ]
preston and he's also driving mm-hmm
you know like we we
we aspire to be shooting content all the
time that's what i'm saying
yeah
today was [ __ ] epic dude
with the kid yeah yeah we got to hurry
up and get that out shout out to you no
a guy one of my friends owns it you and
your friends yeah
what
preston lacy.com oh
oh my god and i just have never had the
gumption to try you know to do anything
with it yeah well if you become the
driver you're going to have a [ __ ] load
of clothes yeah i need to get some merch
going again for sure yeah
for sure man this is selling merge at
shows like uh is the way to be
um and then
you still saving up money to open an
animal sanctuary yeah [ __ ] yeah but we
want to do it in canada so we can't like
we've not been able to cross the border
looking at properties like crazy
like british columbia
um
so yeah we want everyone to follow your
instagram
is this still the real president yeah
yeah the school teacher in kentucky is
preston lacey so so it's real preston
lacy yeah and instagram and then it's
just at preston lacey on twitter that
person lazy on twitter yeah that school
teacher in kentucky told me preston lacy
he said my life was great until you came
along
he goes now they call me mr jackass
i like it
does he say that like tongue-in-cheek
yeah yeah no he's a super nice guy super
happy this is the name he don't care
right well then give us your [ __ ]
handle you [ __ ]
yeah you're not an entertainment
industry there was a guy who had uh
stevo.com
i mean there was and then there's a guy
had at steve on instagram well there was
a you were officially stevo i used to be
officially stevo and then this guy like
i met him and he was cool and he just
gave it to me during the series there
was a guy from san diego named jack ass
who sued the mtv and yeah viacom and
everybody saying that they stole his
name his last name
yeah that got dismissed like a
[ __ ] right out the door yeah
all right well everybody follow [ __ ]
preston on social media yeah and come to
a bucket list tour because they might
see preston [ __ ] at the show and go
see the number three movie in the united
states
that was number two oh there you go we
made number two last week i was
suggesting for when this comes out next
week do you think you think we'll be
kicked down to three yeah no way well
probably four or five at that point
there's new stuff coming out so much i
know we were good we did great
unbelievable i mean the narrative is
even like way better than we did yeah so
yeah we'll take it
yeah no people weren't wanting to go
those theaters you know
all right thank you guys thank you so
much
yeah dudes man couple things it looks
like preston lacy actually
is gonna be our bus driver we gotta uh
figure this one out wow that would be
insane and i know some of you guys uh
have been leaving comments like oh dude
with all the alba ads because i had
covered and couldn't go to the movie
premiere and and because of all the
stuff going on with the movie we missed
two weeks and we were committed to
sponsors to running
we had to pack in all these extra ads
but now we're caught up so it's back to
business as usual and as always thank
you guys for sticking around to the very
end um it's pretty crazy man like i've
been uploading to my main youtube
channel every single week podcast every
single week grueling tour schedule
it's uh a pretty blistering pace that
i'm keeping man and i'm super stoked
yeah man
work work work now time to go bone bone
bone
so take care everybody